foreign
can I ask you about your previous life
when you were an actor and a comedian
um now you're a wartime leader
how do you bring that sense of humor
that you undoubtedly have
to your colleagues in order to keep up
their Spirits I I never I never lost my
sense of humor I think when people lose
it they lose up
it yeah
uh the quietness yeah
the state of mind yeah I think so yes
you have to to concentrate and be very
serious not during monthins
you have to do it in a very important
moments in a very difficult decisions
you have to be worry you have to be
clever and you have to be adequate and
you have to be brave because you are the
leader that's it it's very important
it's not interesting what you feel you
have to do it and you have to change if
you feel that you can't you have to
change very quickly
not to run stay change and make
decisions that is very important and
very important to make decisions quicker
than enemy that is that is very
important not to think it's not about
philosophy or something like like you
know like like this you have you have to
make decisions I think that is steps to
the big victory small steps small
Victoria steps small steps each day each
day you have to you know wake up and
think what we'll do today
to make this Victory closer that is very
important and that's why but to be a
decree you have to sometimes you know
yes in the night I have some you know 15
minutes to think about to speak with
children by phone something like this to
to to to to
not without any crying that it's so
difficult and very huge to leave the
country without all these things it's
it's not I think you will find some
people who will tell about you like in
in you know social media Etc yes without
them without it you have to be strong
and that's why humor uh sense of humor
shows
when you can joke shop sometimes of
course shows that you are okay that you
are strong that you control the
situation
it's very important to control the
uh that's it nobody can make decisions
without you
because then the result so I mean that
the result depends on you yeah so that's
why you have to concentrate and humor
makes you
human
when's the last time you laughed was it
my outfit
oh now once they're gonna go I think
last time yeah and let me let me ask you
this um it's your birthday today yes
happy birthday it's it's not funny
I'm 45 it's not funny what would be the
best gift you could have
the best gift I don't I don't I don't
really I don't like I mean that
I had everything before my presidential
time and before this war and so I I will
not be surprised if we are speaking
about some things you know some material
materials are some material things it's
not interesting yes so
of course of course if our soldiers can
today deoccupate some little little
village it will be great because it's so
it's so difficult it's so difficult like
they go 100 meters 500 300 and then 300
back and then 500 forward so for me the
best present the best present is walking
forward
that's it thank you